[Music]
good to see you my friend it's really
good to be here thank you I think the
last time we did this was two years ago
how long ago was it it was a while ago
yeah it was a little while ago maybe 18
months a little more I remember it was
the dead of winter in New York that's
all I remember it was very cold well
much has happened since then so I'm
excited to have you back to bring us up
to speed on everything clean meat
everything that's happening in the
plant-based food movement you guys just
had a big conference right we did yeah
so talk about that well it was a
conference focused day one was
predominantly on plant-based meat day
two was predominantly unclean meat and
we had kind of everybody who's anybody
in the plant-based meat and the clean
meat market sectors and then we invited
we had two panels on plant-based made in
two panels on clean meat where we
invited people from industry on in the
one case and we invited scientists in
the other case where we think they have
the capacity to basically move these
market sectors forward in a really big
way but they're not currently involved
so for example people who are doing
extruders and people are doing crop
sciences and people who are doing xeno
free media for therapeutics and
basically the real goal of the
conference we wanted people to network
we wanted to connect investors with
startups we wanted to get scientists
more excited about the space but we
really wanted the market sectors that
are currently existing and the
scientists who are currently active
they're not looking at plant based meter
clean meat at the moment but they would
be essential to plant-based and clean
meat accelerating so we brought them and
it was a phenomenal success in that
regard yeah it seems like that's one of
one of the I mean you good food
Institute takes this multi-pronged
approach to you know developing this new
way of thinking about food and and how
we're going to innovate for the future
but one of the more compelling prongs in
your approach is trying to cultivate
cooperation not just amongst all of the
you know sort of major players in the
clean meat and plant-based food movement
but also with the people that are
outside of it that can contribute to
this rapidly growing revolution that
we're experiencing right now so so what
came out of that like what what were you
know what are some of the things that
are happening right now in this world
that are perhaps new since we last spoke
well there is a tremendous amount that's
new since we last spoke so all of GFI's
departments are ramping up which I'm
very excited about and what you just
said is true we see ourselves on
certainly is helping the current players
so the current startups and the current
companies that exist in plant-based meat
and clean me to help them all to
coordinate across a variety of sectors
from science to policy to networking
with sort of big corporations big food
corporations and meat corporations but
we also really want to create a pipeline
of scientists we really want to get the
therapeutics industry that exists
thinking about cross application of what
it is that they're doing to the food
sector in other words to clean meat we
want to get people who are currently
funding for the environment or
sustainability or global health thinking
about the value of funding plant-based
meat and clean meat R&D so we're doing a
lot across our programmatic areas that
GFI and there's a tremendous amount
that's happened since the last time we
talked right I had 13 or 14 staff now we
have 53 probably be more than 70 by the
end of the year in the US and hopefully
somewhere in the order of 20
internationally so a lot happening but
the conference really worked for that
there were people who run extruder
companies and people who run media
company isn't scientists who are working
in tissue engineering and people who are
doing plant biology and they came to the
conference and they learned about how
much good they can do in the world while
also doing very well for themselves if
they refocus some of their efforts into
plant-based meat and clean meat really
excited by an email that I got from a
Berkeley professor in the Plant Sciences
Department and she said that she came to
the conference just sorted to explore
what was happening yeah and she walked
away completely enthused and talking
about how she will be educating her
students about this and encouraging them
to take the class we designed at
Berkeley and plant-based meat and clean
meat and to think of
focusing their careers here and that was
just replicated over and over and over
again with people at really big food
companies people who are in therapeutics
who are in crop sciences who are
thinking about you know chemical
engineering and mechanical engineering
and they're currently in the food
industry and now they're thinking about
plant-based meat and clean meat and how
they can plug in it's very exciting
that's cool so yeah you guys created or
are behind the very first college course
on clean meat right and is that it
Berkeley Berkeley and we're launching
one this semester at Stanford and Penn
State we've got a MOOC that will be
coming out in the next what some five or
six weeks massive on open online course
okay so it will be an an 11th Lee an
11th week sort of crash course in
plant-based meat and clean meat and it
seems like it's it's a subject matter
that really is multi-disciplinarian
right because you have to understand
chemistry you have to understand cell
biology like you have to understand
engineering you have to understand I
don't know brewing like what do you need
to understand to really wrap your head
around what clean meat is and what is
going on and how we're gonna innovate
this future
well it's not super hard to understand
it's sort of a basic level but as with
any sort of production scale food supply
there is a tremendous amount that you
need to understand about sort of each
sector so you know for plant-based me we
need to be doing crop optimization and
we need to figure out you know what are
the proteins that are going to be best
turned into plant-based meat and we need
to figure out what that looks like then
we need to look at figure out you know
how you put all these things together in
order to make something that bio mimics
meat and you need to figure out what the
production technology is going to be
it's really sort of fascinating to us on
when we first started looking at
plant-based meat and clean meat we sort
of thought we had plant-based meat
figure it out because they're a bunch of
companies doing it and clean meat was
going to be really complex and difficult
because nobody essentially was doing it
Memphis meats was just getting started
right there was super meat and Mohsen
meats just getting started
none of the three of them had
incorporated but what we found is that
the plant-based meat is actually a lot
more complex than the clean meat because
clean me we've got cross applicability
therapeutic from tissue engineering so
everything happening in George church's
lab at Harvard Medical School you could
just like sort of take all of that and
say okay we're going to do food now and
start producing clean meat with plant
based mate you've sort of got the
pioneers beyond meat and impossible
foods but there is limitless other stuff
that could be happening and even
impossible foods and beyond meat are
pretty tiny when you compare them to you
know sort of the big meat industry or
cell therapeutics so a tremendous amount
to learn at its most basic level though
plant-based meat is let's take plants
you know there's nothing in me that
doesn't exist in plants meat is lipids
and amino zand minerals and water let's
figure out how we take those constituent
parts put them together and process them
so that they biomimic meat so that they
give everything people everything that
they like about me but using plants and
because it's so much more efficient it
will be less expensive and then clean
meat is similar except you take the
products of tissue engineering so how
are we gonna grow cells how we're gonna
put them on scaffold so that they can
grow how we're gonna put them into into
a bioreactor like what does this look
like at food-grade which obviously has
to be significantly less expensive than
tissue engineering yeah yeah well I want
to get into clean meat but let's start
with plant-based meat it seems that pea
protein has sort of been the protein of
choice as a foundational basis for
creating these foods are we moving in
different directions now like what you
know where are we
sourcing those nutrients the lipids the
proteins and what does that future look
like yeah I mean this is one of the sort
of interesting aha moments for us when
we were thinking about plant-based meat
and clean meat and the fact that up
until Ethan Brown comes along in 2009 so
Ethan was working Ethan's the founder of
beyond meat right and he was working in
clean energy and he read the UN report
about the climate change impact of the
meat industry and he pretty much
simultaneously at about the same time
heard about some peen research that was
going on at the University of Minister
and the idea of using peas to basically
get you the taste the texture other
things that people liked about me and he
jumped in and that was sort of the first
time anybody had ever looked at crops
with the idea of optimizing them to
create something that tastes like meat
up until that point all of the companies
were using either wheat or soy and it
was the waste product of wheat and soy
so for weed it was the waste product of
carbohydrates for soy it was the waste
product of oil and it was sort of let's
cram this stuff together and make
vegetarians eat it right so we can just
you know not have to throw stuff away
and maybe created an additional revenue
stream yeah I know that our main
business exactly but it was basically it
was basically the waste product so P
protein was was the first if the
proteins to really be optimized for
plant-based meat and other companies
have jumped on board but there's really
no reason it should be P protein so
people are looking at lupine they're
looking at lentils they're looking at
oats really kind of any source that has
protein and impossible foods is using
potato protein and yeah and they're use
that they're optimizing potato protein
for they for the impossible burgers so
even products that you don't generally
think of as being particularly high
protein really kind of any crop and this
goes back to that Bill Gates line when
he tried beyond meats plant-based
chicken and he wrote a blog called the
future of food and he said what I just
tasted it's not just a clever meat
substitute it is the future of food and
the title of the the title of the
article he said 92% of plant protein
plants have not been explored for their
capacity to be turned into plant-based
meat so and that's still true and it's
also true that most of the work that's
going on in this space is protected by
yet IP it's going on in private
universities so one of the things we're
doing at GFI is really trying hard
through our science team to change that
and we're launching fellowship programs
we're identifying the top 24
universities globally for plant-based
meat and clean meat in the top 20 for
universities in the US for plant-based
meat and clean me most of these
universities are doing nothing now but
they have the you know they have the
basic agricultural sciences or the basic
tissue engineering or biochemistry
they have the right departments they
have the right funding they have the
right research focus and we're gonna be
going to them and strongly encouraging
them to to put some of the resources
into plant-based meat and clean me yeah
I would think that the universities that
have strong agricultural Studies
programs would would be obvious choices
but I'm wondering whether you get
pushback from them because there's a
certain stat
and that perhaps the the universities
with strong engineering programs and
science you know science focus might be
more open to you know the possibility of
the future I mean have you had those
kind of conversations have you gotten
pushback from the academic sector not so
far I mean it may happen so but so far
there's there's uniform enthusiasm I
mean and this goes to sort of one of the
other revelations of this space is that
the vast majority of people working in
the meat industry are not especially
excited to be working in the meat
industry they have the noble goal of
supplying high quality protein to lots
of people inexpensively I mean if that's
your goal and that's what it is for you
know pretty much everybody at a place
like Tyson or Purdue or Smithfield if
that's your goal this is a better way to
do that it's also generally the goal
even at the land-grant universities so I
mean I think cattle ranching and
regenerative agriculture are sort of the
two exceptions to that but the vast
majority of what happens in the meat
industry doesn't have to involve raising
live animals and it doesn't have to
involve slaughter and so we generally
meet with enthusiasm especially when we
start talking to people about how this
is like you know there's a lot of
discomfort err in the meat industry
about undercover investigations about
the link to antibiotic resistance about
the link to climate change about animal
slaughter and this gets people past all
of that while doing still what is their
fundamental goal which is let's let's
produce high quality protein for people
to eat right right well it's undeniable
that this is on the rise I mean I was
looking at some of the statistics and
and they're pretty staggering I mean a
17 percent growth in the plant-based
food sector 23 percent growth and
plant-based meets the plant-based food
sector is now a three point seven
billion dollar industry I mean these are
gigantic numbers and when you see that
growth curve that portends you know
optimism for the future yeah absolutely
I mean some of these companies beyond me
grew at 70% and if they had been able to
supply more they would have been able to
grow a lot more quickly than that that
was literally the max they could produce
on field roast was just south of that
Guardian was just south
that in the entire plant-based meat
sector as you said grow at a rate of
more than 20% if you stay on that
trajectory which is roughly the
trajectory that plant-based milk was on
if you stay on that trajectory you're
literally at a huntress 100% by 2050 so
it's 1/3 of 1% now if you wouldn't
incorporate also restaurants it's about
1 it's about 1% just at grocery it's 1/3
of 1% once you incorporate restaurants
you stay on that trajectory next year
you're only at like 0.5 right on in
about seven years you're at 1% but in 35
years you're at 100% if you're growing
at about you know 1.2 per year uh-huh
and that's the GFI goal that is the GI
goal I mean we'll be incorporated and
cleaning it into it as well but if X is
plant-based meat and Y is clean me the
goal is that X plus y equals roughly 100
there will still be some regenerative
agriculture in there I'm not sure what
percentage that will be but but mostly
yeah mostly it's a plant-based meat and
clean meat they're more efficient
they're better in all these myriad ways
it's just a better way of producing meat
well when Bill Gates made that statement
I mean that was definitely a watershed
moment and then he's put his money
behind his words I know he's invested in
beyond me I'm sure he's invested in you
would know better like I'm well you know
all kinds of these companies Peter teal
is jumping in now he just invested in
what in like lab-grown meat for pets
it's right you know like who would have
thought so this is happening we have the
impossible burger in White Castle which
is crazy announced nationwide I think
that might have been white castles
fastest from regional to national
international I know that for beyond
meat and TGI Fridays it was TGI Fridays
fastest from regional to national
introduction oh that's amazing and why
aren't we seeing either beyond meat or
the impossible burger or some variation
thereof in every fast-food restaurant
I'm sure these conversations are
happening in boardrooms you know across
the world
I know McDonald's was running a pilot
program like in the Netherlands or
someplace like that with a with a veggie
burger but it would seem that the time
is ripe that that all of these major
chains would at least be testing this at
the moment well I mean they might want
to be testing it but
would I encounter everywhere I go is
people saying why can't I get the
impossible burger why can't I get the
beyond burger and they literally are
producing as fast as they can possibly
Susan they simply can't meet watching
situation right now we just need scale
yeah I mean I don't know for sure that's
why McDonald's doesn't have the beyond
burger or the impossible burger although
there were people from McDonald's and
other fast-food and big meat industry
players at our conference who were super
enthused about the experience and what
they were hearing but I don't know
what's happening in the boardroom at
McDonald's but I do know that if they
came to impossible or beyond me and and
said we would like to have your burger
nationwide neither of those companies at
least right at the moment that would
have to be a negotiation for the future
yeah well let's take a step back and
just kind of canvas the landscape in
terms of you know the benefits of moving
in this direction from a variety of
perspectives
obviously clean meat avoids having to
kill animals for food it's it's it's
better on on the climate there's a
health argument there's all of these
reasons but I think it would be good and
we probably covered this last time we
spoke but there's a lot of new people
that are listening now that might not
have listened to our first conversation
let's talk first about the climate let's
talk about the impact of animal
agriculture on the climate and how you
see this new revolution in plant-based
foods being a curative to the ills that
we're currently facing and this
dystopian future that that you know lies
in you know that will fall into the lap
of future generations if we don't figure
this out yeah I mean the two big
questions and food are how do we feed
nine point seven billion people by 2050
and what do we do about climate change
and plant basement and and coming up
what do we do about global health like
antibiotics is up and coming as a
concern and according to the UK
government is a bigger concern for the
human race they on climate change so
those are sort of the big three and they
interlink at least the first two
interlink so raising crops to feed them
to animals so that we can eat animals
is just vastly inefficient and it's the
same as you know the vast majority of
what we doesn't go into gaining weight
the vast majority of what we eat sorry
ok the best of podcast but I know I'm
very excited about that I'm glad it's
not live the vast majority of what we
eat goes into just allowing us to lead
our lives and that's true for farm
animals as well so the most efficient
meat is chicken and yet it takes nine
calories into a chicken to get one
calorie back out explain that for people
that are unfamiliar with how this whole
thing works
yeah so I mean it makes intuitive sense
right so I weigh about 185 pounds if I
do nothing but lay in bed watching bad
television not even moving I'm gonna
burn like 2,400 calories every single
time what if you watch good television
well if it gets me excited I suppose my
adrenaline could go a little bit up if
I'm shouting at the television if it's
sports and I care who's gonna win or
something but I mean basically our
metabolism or my metabolism is gonna
burn about 2,400 calories a day and
that's just physiologically what I need
just to keep my body doing the same sort
of thing is true for farm animals the
vast majority of the calories that you
feed them they need just to exist and so
that it takes nine calories into a
chicken to get one calorie back out in
the form of that animals flesh sometimes
the industry will do a mass to live
weight conversion from mass to live
weight you can get to like 2.2 or
something like that but about half of
the calories in go into bones and blood
and feathers and other things that we
don't eat and then you really have to
like have dense calories to get that
mass calorie out conversion what really
matters is energy and energy out we ate
those crops directly you get 9 calories
instead of one calorie
if you funnel those crops through a
chicken so that means 9 times as much
land 9 times as much water
9 times as much pesticide and herbicide
9 times as much fossil fuel to power the
combines and then you're growing all of
those crops you're shipping those crops
to a feed mill you're operating the feed
mill you're shipping the feed to the
farm you're operating the farm shipping
the animals to the slaughterhouse you're
operating the slaughterhouse just a
vastly inefficient system the nine in
one out is vastly inefficient and then
you total all of the inefficiencies all
of the extra stages of production all of
the gas guzzling pollution spewing
vehicles all of the extra factor
and what you find is that a conservative
estimate is that about 13.5 percent
according to the United Nations about
13.5 percent of all climate change is
attributable to the meat industry it's
more than all transportation combined on
it yeah and that's a that's a
conservative estimate from what I
understand right I think in kal spear C
they said it was 15 percent I think it
depends on how you run the numbers but
thirteen point five is pretty you know
that's that's being conservative and
it's still trumps transportation which
is what we're all focused on yeah I mean
and food waste which people are focused
on I mean food waste is 40 percent of
everything we grow we throw away and
obviously that's bad but this is a
literally 800 percent food waste
literally you're throwing away eight
calories for every calorie that you
consume and then you're stacking on top
of this that all of these extra
factories all of these other 18 wheelers
driving around moving stuff and I mean
it just environmentally the United
Nations said no matter what
environmental issue you're looking at
from the smallest and most local to the
largest and most global so its loss of
biodiversity its water pollution its
water use its soil desertification its
chopping down the rainforest every
single issue the meat industry is one of
the top two or three global causes of
that issue including climate change I
meant on per calorie basis somebody sits
down and they eat chicken which is the
least climate change inducing me that's
four thousand percent of the climate
change as if you were eating like owns
like soy or peas forty times as much on
a per calorie basis for that meal it's a
total insanity it is total insanity this
and what does it look like with beef
well it's even worse it's about 25
calories in to get one calorie back out
so it's you know two thousand four
hundred percent it's and so you're
throwing away twenty four calories for
every calorie that you consume I'm a 330
times on a per calorie basis I pulled
that out of the recesses of my brain
it's a Lancet article from I think 2015
but 330 times as much climate change per
calorie of protein for beef as opposed
for two for legumes like soy and not soy
un Peas so the UN report that was 2008
it was yeah 18 percent one the in 2008
they said 18 percent and then I think in
2013 or 20
14 they said thirteen point five right
and then there was this Chatham House
report as well right a couple years
later well there's a world watch report
that was put together Chatham House
Chatham House had a really interesting
report Chatham House the Royal Institute
of International Affairs which is the
foremost think-tank in Europe and they
released a report that said unless an
animal product consumption goes down on
every country no country is going to be
able to keep climate change under two
degrees Celsius by 2050 which is the
Paris climate agreement um yeah that is
the Paris climate agreement yes no
country can do it unless their meat
consumption goes down and they
recommended that we educate populations
about this issue and then world watch
did a report from a World Bank
agricultural economist and an IFC
International Finance Corporation
agricultural economist in which they
basically disputed the UN numbers and
they said actually climate change more
than fifty percent of it is attributable
to animal agriculture and that's pretty
easy to find it just Google Worldwatch
Institute climate change World Bank
it'll be like the first thing to pop but
we tend to focus on the thirteen point
behind because it's still more than
transportation it's still awful and and
certainly should be should be motivating
to people yeah it's it's shocking it's
shocking that we're not talking about
this more like what are the barriers to
really being able to penetrate
mainstream awareness to elevate this
discussion to the highest level and and
really you know I know you're doing
everything you can a GFI but what do you
see as the biggest impediments or the
challenges that you face in trying to
get people to really understand this and
and and make change well Rick we're not
actually trying to get people to
understand this and make change like igf
ice theory of change is that we have
beat our head against a wall of
education for decades we have attempted
to convince people to change their diets
with educated people about climate we've
educated them about the inefficiency I
mean Francis Moore lepay wrote the book
that turned me vegan more than thirty
years ago she wrote it almost 50 years
ago now and it makes the arguments that
we're making now about the environmental
impact and the inefficiency pete has
been around since 1980 telling people
about the harm to animals environmental
groups have been talking about the
inefficiency cowspiracy
what the health phenomenal films and yet
in 2017 per capita meat consumption in
the US was the highest it's ever been in
US history the 2018 is going to be even
higher so I mean GFI CEOs are global
it's both it's both it's a light it's
skyrocketing globally but it's up in the
u.s. highest it's ever been I mean
people are generally pretty shocked by
that sometimes people even say well is
that because the populations bigger and
I'm still per per capita 2017 high it's
interesting that that is in tandem with
with the growing you know market of
plant-based foods and plant-based meats
it is ya know it's it's super
interesting and I think I think we will
see this turn as we give people what
they want on but produced in a different
way so the theory of change of
impossible foods are beyond me of just
of these companies the theory of change
is let's actually give people everything
that they like about meat and dairy and
eggs except let's make it less expensive
and so it will sell more and let's just
replace it because every single survey
that's ever been done indicates that
what people make their dietary decisions
on the basis of its price its taste its
convenience a lot of us who are having
this conversations are like will we shop
at the farmers market or we shop at
Whole Foods or we shop at our local
co-op which my wife and I do in all
three cases and we get this vision of
people who are very mindful about the
food that they're eating but even watch
what people are eating at Whole Foods
like that entire sector is less than 2%
so 98% is Albertsons and Target and Holt
and Walmart and sort of that sort of
grocery like really big grocery yeah but
even could watch what people are eating
at Whole Foods I mean even that even
folks at Whole Foods it's like the price
matters and the taste matters and
whether it's healthy for them is not
that high on the scale which is why
obesity rates they actually these maps
that are sort of color-coded for obesity
they have to keep adding new colors
because people are getting fatter and
fatter and fatter and fatter so you at
GFI you're like all right forget about
like trying to educate people that's
that's a non-starter look we're making
for the amount of like you use the nine
calories in one calorie out it's like
you know a thousand calories into trying
to get people to change their habits
versus what you're getting out so
instead you have this
focus on trying to leverage basically
market forces to incentivize companies
to innovate and to create products that
people like that address these problems
yeah no its markets and food technology
and that will be the transformation and
we do talk about you know how do we feed
nine point seven billion people by 2050
we talk in sort of an uber way about
keeping antibiotics working because
governments care about those things and
we want governments to be supporting
research and development and plant-based
meat and clean me that's a big part of
what our policy Department does it's a
big part of what our international
engagement folks are doing in India and
Israel and China and Singapore in Brazil
which is the areas where we're
particularly active and governments you
know these plant-based made and clean
meat they're their solution there they
are how governments meet their
obligations under the Paris climate
agreement they're how governments
provide safe food food safety is a big
issue especially in places like China
and India they're how water is conserved
there how resources are conserved so we
talk about these things but we talk
about them to people who are doing
policy so fund these things roll out the
regulatory red carpet for clean meat if
you are a philanthropist or an impact
investor and what you care about is
climate change or sustainability or
global health these are things that you
should be investing in if you're a
foundation and you do grant make in the
in these areas you should be doing grant
making on these issues but for
individual consumers it's really go try
the impossible burger it tastes
incredibly awesome and then you can also
talk about the impact on the climate or
the impact on sustainability or whatever
once people are you know already
thinking oh this is like an awesome new
food at this hot new restaurant it
tastes amazing oh and I can also feel
good about the fact that I'm doing
something awesome for the planet or it's
healthier or whatever else right well
this approach seems to be working I mean
there's a huge upswing in venture
capital funds that are investing in this
sector we're seeing a rapidly changing
regulatory landscape which I want to get
into with you and the money is flowing
and the innovation is happening and it's
happening quickly yeah and at our
conference we were just delighted to see
so like the biggest plant-based meat
meat company is Morningstar farms they
are doing a lot of innovation internally
I mean it was interesting to see sort of
beyond meat and impossible foods come up
and they suddenly like the old guard
exactly yeah and and so sort of the the
legacy companies saw what happened with
impossible foods and beyond mean like
Google Ventures and is investing in
impossible foods and dfj is investing in
Memphis meats and so the companies that
are already sort of established like
Morningstar farms and Guardian and
tofurkey they're like really upping
their innovation game and response to
this I think they sort of saw their
market sector as being roughly you know
it caps it maybe six hundred million
dollars now they're seeing their market
sector as it caps at two hundred billion
dollars and they're taking that very
very seriously all those guys sponsored
the conference they were at the
conference they're having these
conversations and they're doing a lot of
really exciting work internally yeah and
and that that relatively bland soy patty
just ain't gonna cut it anymore
you better up your game yeah unless you
want to stay I mean even you know now
even vegetarians aren't gonna settle for
that right I'm saying yeah no that's
exactly right but I mean a lot of these
people like I mean I just love listening
to like Pat Brown on and Ethan Brown no
relation but Pat Brown from impossible
and Ethan Brown from beyond talk about
their vision for their company and both
of those guys see themselves as running
meat companies and their competition is
the entire meat industry their goal is
to take some significant slice of the
200 billion dollars a year that is the
u.s. meat market yeah this is the future
this is happening the train is pulled
out of the station and I think it's a
wake-up call for the industry in all of
its status quo to either understand that
they need to get on board or that
they're going to be quickly antiquated
so you're seeing the Cargill's and the
Tyson's investing in these companies
because they realize that if they want
to be if they want to continue to exist
they're gonna need to jump on this train
yeah the cover story of Businessweek was
about the CEO of Tyson a guy named Tom
Hayes so just in early September 2018
the cover story was about him and the
final sentence of the story was if we
can make meat without the animal why
wouldn't we
right so second largest meat company in
the world by far the biggest meat
company in the United States and of
their first date they launched a venture
capital fund in 2016 of their first four
and
meant to work clean meat companies one
was a plant-based meat company and they
are all in on plant-based meat and clean
meat and it just underlines the fact
that like these guys like most of the
people who are executives in this
country company they could have ended up
at you know anywhere they could have
ended up selling t-shirts right I mean
they went to business school and they
sort of worked their way up the
corporate ladder and they found
themselves at Tyson and they see
themselves as nobly feeding the world
high quality protein at a low cost they
can feed the world higher quality
protein at a lower cost with plant-based
meat and cleanly they will make more
money and they won't have all the
headaches of the owner that come with
farms and slaughterhouses and all of the
external costs that are involved yeah
all right so let's assume there's a lot
of people that that are just being
introduced to this idea of clean meat
for the very first time explain to me
what it is how we create it and why it's
so exciting
sure so right now if you want to get
meat you feed an animal and the animal
grows so the animals cells multiply and
grow and then you slaughter the animal
and you eat the meat as we've been
talking about it is a horribly
inefficient process that comes with a
lot of external costs that are not good
in it it's much I mean factory farming
is one of the most efficient I mean if
you're going to raise an animal for food
they figured out the most efficient way
to do it yeah I mean they blow this
animal up in the shortest period of time
to create the most food out of it and
yet it's still inherently systemically
completely completely inefficient yeah I
mean it's the basic physiology that we
just talked about I mean they now have
chickens growing seven times as quickly
as they would naturally answer chickens
as opposed to like the 1919 and 1920s
and 30s
they're now growing seven times as
quickly as they would naturally they are
fed massive doses of antibiotics they
barely move so that their caloric
conversion is as good as it can possibly
be and it's just the nature of
physiology that you can't do much better
than nine in four one out
that's just mmm that's what you can do
and they might be able to get a little
bit more efficient but not a lot more
efficient right and pigs are worse
farmed fish or worse cattle or worse
lambs are worse so it's just it is a bad
system if your goal is to convert
food into protein if your goal is to
convert you know one food into me it's a
really bad way of doing that so with
clean me what you do is you take you can
take a biopsy from any animal you take a
couple of cells very limited number of
cells you bathe those cells in nutrients
which is basically the equivalent of
feeding the animal except that all of
the energy goes into causing those cells
to multiply and grow you don't have the
50% waste that comes with farm animals
50% of the farm animal we don't need and
it's just a far more efficient way of
causing the cells to multiply and grow
you can do it on a scaffold or not on a
scaffold if you want like a chicken
breast you need a scaffold you do it in
basically a scaffold being like a sort
of simulated skeleton to grow these
cells around yeah exactly it's it's
basically a simulated skeleton except
the scaffolds that they use you can
actually you can usually either have
them biodegrade or you can have them be
edible so either of those works so you
don't end up with something you have to
throw away at the end like the bones or
you have to you know turn into dog food
or cat food or whatever they're gonna do
with the bones and so then you put it in
basically a giant sort of meat fermenter
at end stage it looks like a brewery so
you could literally have you know a meat
and beer brewery and both of the vats
you know both of the sort of meat
fermenter and the beer fermenter I think
folks are now calling the meat one a
cultivator and so you've got the
cultivator you've got the fermenter and
out is coming beer through sort of a
chemical process and out is coming meat
through essentially a chemical process
the food is a lot purer I mean it takes
far fewer resources but it also because
there's no intestinal tract it doesn't
have the Salmonella or the Campylobacter
or the e.coli or the other you know food
poisoning concern products doesn't
require anti Antep any antibiotics which
I mean you know we haven't talked that
much about that but GFI were talking a
lot more about antibiotics you want to
scare Google antibiotic at the end of
working antibiotics you know a real
punch in the word China China is using
antibiotics that are banned in the US
and the u.s. is pretty liberal about
which antibiotics they will allow to be
used in food 70% of antibiotics that
pharmaceuticals are producing in the
United States 70% of them are being fed
to farm animals not because the animals
are sick but because the animals are in
awful conditions in which they would get
sick if they weren't fed prophylactic
antibiotics
yeah and and not to kill the lily but
we're ingesting those antibiotics and
were basically you know paving the way
for the cultivation of some kind of
super bug that could create a pandemic
or an epidemic yeah I mean we are we are
consuming the antibiotics that's not the
real health risk although it is it is
certainly concerning Nicholas Kristof
wrote a piece for the New York Times a
few years ago about some research out of
Johns Hopkins University where Hopkins
analyzed chicken flesh and found that
there was like the active ingredient in
benadryl and Prozac and aspirin and
antibiotics like in the meat so that's
bad enough but the real risk factor is
the superbugs what happens is you're
feeding the animals the antibiotics and
the Campylobacter elect tries to infect
the animal and it fails because at the
anti put antibiotic and then that bug
mutates so that it can get around to the
antibiotics and then you scrape your
knee or you cut your finger or you know
whatever happens and you're given
antibiotics and the antibiotics don't
work because now there are these
superbugs and what used to be you know a
routine infection ends up you have to
lop off your arm I mean it's according
to the UK government the end of working
antibiotics is a greater threat to the
human race than climate change right now
about 10,000 people in North America and
Europe are dying from superbugs they're
saying it will be 10 million people per
year if we stay on this trajectory and
it's slated to cost the global economy a
hundred trillion dollars by 2050 bigger
threat than climate change that's
unbelievable
and solvable I mean it's unbelievable
and it's solvable so like we're not
talking about that either I know yeah I
know that that one isn't even being
talked about like folks are talking at
sort of government levels and foundation
levels like a lot of people are talking
about how do we solve climate change yes
and thanks to tank culture well yes but
we need think tank culture talking a lot
more about antibiotics as well so this
is the one I mean like at GSI and we're
doing a ton of work we have more than 50
staff are you know we're trying to raise
7.5 million dollars this year like we're
doing a lot of stuff but this is this
isn't big we're not thinking well we're
thinking big enough but at like the real
solution is the philanthropists who care
about climate change the governments who
care about these issues they should
be sinking you know clean energy level
resources into this it should we
shouldn't be thinking in terms of you
know seven point five million dollars
look at Update gif is we should be
thinking in terms of seven hundred and
fifty billion dollars this is a solvable
issue we can knock out the anti but
level we can significantly ameliorate
the main cause of antibiotic resistance
we can significantly ameliorate one of
the principal causes of climate change
water pollution antibiotic resistance
food poisoning like all of these issues
there should be like Harvard Medical
School should have a 60 million dollar
clean meat Research Institute Cornell
should have a 60 million dollar per year
Oh sixty million dollars to get it going
plant-based meat Research Institute
government should be funding this
foundation should be funding this just a
big part of what GFI is doing in our
international offices a big part of what
our policy Department is doing big part
of what our science department is doing
is trying to you know reach people like
Marc Benioff and you know people who are
like interested in these issues and say
this deserves really significant
resources yeah we need an
interdisciplinary Manhattan Project
we need a whole bunch of them right yeah
we need an interdisciplinary Manhattan
Project for sure but just like you know
Georgetown Law School has a climate
center which most people haven't heard
of because it's not one of the ten best
climate centers or maybe it is I hope I
didn't just define them but there are
tons of climate Institute's at like
every major university in the country
and there should be Institute's focused
on plant-based meat and clean meat at
least for a start at the 24 global
universities that we've just identified
people can check them out at GFI dot org
it's on our blog we're about to be
releasing the top I think 13 or 14 in
the United States for plant-based made
and clean me like all of these
universities none of them have it now
all of them should have institutes all
of them should have disciplines you know
that Berkeley had the first plant-based
meat and clean meat class that we
designed last year now we've got one at
Stanford and Penn State every University
that has a Sciences Department should
have how do we apply science to food
plant-based meat and clean meat right so
clean meat sort of comes online what was
it like five years ago Oh less than that
no the yeah yeah 20 2015 on valetti
starts working on Memphis meets 2015
mark post starts working on most amazed
and the guys that super mates start
working on super mate Memphis meets is
incorporated in April 2016 that's the
first company ever to incorporate on
clean meters everything I thought there
was the one in Japan that wasn't that a
little earlier no in Turkic culture they
were they actually just incorporated as
a company they might have started
working on it in 2014 or 2015 I mean the
first clean meat conference at
Maastricht University in the Netherlands
was in October of 2015
new harvests which is a nonprofit
organization and cellular agriculture
their first conference was in November
of 2015 so this is a really really new
and they're now 30 companies 30 clean
meat companies around the world and
probably about 20 of them have raised
you know $500,000 or more so it's still
super nascent but it's it's optimistic
it's an interesting thing because we're
talking about it it is happening it's
going to happen we're gonna figure out
how to scale this whole thing but much
like the autumn the automation of cars
nobody's tried this yeah you know it's
like it's something we're talking about
that's very academic and kind of
ephemeral and you know theoretical in
most people's minds you know people that
that even know the slightest bit about
it all they know is okay they're growing
cells it's a three hundred thousand
dollar burger you know this is not a I'm
grossed out and it's too expensive yeah
this is gonna solve anybody's problems
and I just just step back I mean we wish
it were more academic like this is this
is one of the things we're trying to
solve for is there are 30 companies and
what that means is there are 30
different companies trying to solve from
the ground up how do we grow meat from
cells what does it look like to get
immortalized cells what should the
scaffolding look like what should the
bio reactors look like like what should
the media look like that feeds the cells
it's 30 different companies all
protecting their own IP working in this
sector so one of the things that
absolutely needs to happen is a serious
infusion of cash into the Academy that
does that basically says ok here is you
know here's how we're working on media
all of you companies can use this here's
what bioreactor scale-up looks like all
of you companies can use that so at GFI
we published the cover story in food
technology which is the professional
Journal of the Institute of Food
we published a peer-reviewed journal
article in biochemical engineering
journal and we're doing a lot more
peer-reviewed research we also just got
a two million dollar grant from a
philanthropist in New Jersey No 1
million dollar grant from a philanthropy
philanthropist in New Jersey and two
million dollar grant from a
philanthropist in Massachusetts and we
are announcing a call for proposals and
we will be going to all of the one our
research institutions in the United
States and we will also be going to all
of the universities we've identified as
being most promising for plant-based
meat and clean Maine so we have three
million dollars dedicated to this it
doesn't come out of our general
operating budget it's just for this but
it should be tens of millions of dollars
and it should be you know George Church
and other like top tissue engineering
pooh-bahs and top crop biology and plant
sciences like these folks should be
spearheading this and it should be what
shouldn't even be tens of millions of
dollars it should be you know billions
of dollars because this is solution this
solution to really big problems but we
are excited about what we're going to be
able to do with the three million
dollars like we will at least be able to
put this on to the agenda at people at
all of these schools we're also
launching fellowship programs at about
twenty five science schools we have six
fellows at six of the top ten business
schools and the focus is basically if
you are a tissue engineer we want you to
be thinking about this as possibly your
vocation and applying to work at some of
these companies if you are a business
person and you're gonna come out of
Business School and maybe you're gonna
and you know who knows we're gonna end
up we want to make sure those folks know
about plant-based meat and clean me as a
place that they could apply their
talents do a ton of good in the world
well cymose simultaneously doing really
well for their families but this just
needs a huge injection of cash and it
needs a huge injection of talent and
that's one of the things that we're
trying to catalyze and GFI that's a
that's a huge that's a lot of progress
since the last time we talked I don't
think you were doing really any of that
it'll two years ago right yeah I mean we
went we were I think we're about a 12
staff members then or fifty three staff
members now I think we had maybe three
or four of our directors at that point
now we have all nine of our directors
everybody is thinking super
strategically you know we have quarterly
goals we have sort of everything tied
we've got a strategic plan that anybody
wants to see it and say
I'm in kind of everything down but we do
have a lot of job openings the last time
I was on I was talking about job
openings and I think we got at least
four or five of our current 53 person
staff people who people who listen to me
on the podcast so I hope people will
will check out GFI org or if you don't
see job openings there that are
interesting to you feel free to email me
directly yeah make sure you dial up that
resume though yes Reese only wants good
people it's true ya know we people we
have we have a bit of a reputation for
having a rigorous application process so
if you make it into the application
process it is multiple stages we I mean
you know look at the if you look at GFI
org and click on our team you can see
the caliber of people who we have hired
to work for us it is and all of those
people are working for I said the thing
that was somewhat disparaging about the
idea of people changing their diet on
behalf of these factors but people do
want their vocations to be meaningful
and and at GFI Daniel pink in his book
Drive he says the things people want out
of their vocation they want
self-actualization they want something
that's meaningful they want to be
challenged but not too challenged every
six months we do an internal anonymous
staff survey and we are knocking it out
of the charts on those things it's a
phenomenal place to work but a hard
place to get a job yeah well I think
that's we're seeing more and more of
that Purpose Driven young people who
really prioritized that perhaps even
more than salary and I think that's a
that that gives me hope for the new
generation the next generation C or
whatever it is whatever we're calling it
ya know the cover letter the cover
letters that we read are just so
inspiring on people you know a they
think they can change the world and B
they want to change the world it is
really yeah it's really really good yeah
alright so give me an estimate of how
long it's gonna be before clean meat is
gonna be commercially available to
consumers um I mean I think commercially
available at a price point that is
somewhat reasonable commercially
similar to like grass gram grass-fed
beef probably three or four maybe five
years commercially available at really
low price
points probably 10 years I would guess
but you know what China wants to be the
global leader on climate change
Singapore is looking in a big way at
food tech to feed its population and you
know it's this tiny little country if
Israel or Singapore or China or the u.s.
if they decide they're going to sink
billions of dollars into advancing this
technology could happen a lot more
quickly I mean you know this this it
shouldn't be Sand Hill Road venture
capitalists and with you know a bit of
VC money from Tyson Foods and Cargill
and you know other companies like that
that are seeding plant-based meat and
clean meat is a solution to really big
problems that governments care about
governments should be sinking a lot of
money into this if we convinced them to
do that and that's like one of the key
things that we're doing in our overseas
offices and it's a key aspect of what
our policy Department is doing in the US
we convinced them to do that if we find
you know people with ties into
government who are really excited about
this it could happen a lot more quickly
right so the bottlenecks aren't the
bottlenecks in terms of the timeline
aren't necessarily technological
breakthroughs no it's just sort of
supply chain economics talent money I
mean it's talent and money so I mean
even beyond meat and impossible foods
like they're scaling up as fast as they
can but they can't meet demand right the
other plant-based meat companies
multiple of them are having trouble
meeting demand and you know as I
mentioned beyond meat they sold 70
percent you're on your growth in terms
of sales last year field roast which has
been around for a little while
they sold I think like 65% more Gardein
was like 60% more actually a little more
like 64% more so they're scaling up kind
of as fast as I can and with clean meat
there are some technological hurdles
like we need to take the what we know
about tissue engineering and we need to
figure out how to make you know food
grade media how to scale up the
bioreactor so we have 20,000 liter bio
actors bioreactors instead of 5 liter
bio reactors so there are some questions
to answer there isn't anybody who's like
really deep in this who thinks these are
going to be insurmountable obstacles but
they're going to take you know really
smart scientists and they're going to
take money and if we're continuing to
rely on Silicon Valley and you know 22
150 million dollar investments it's
going to take a lot longer than if we
have multi-billion dollar government you
know a Manhattan Project from China or
the US or whoever assuming or presuming
that we will resolve these you know
economic dilemmas that there will be an
adequate cash infusion and all of this
stuff is going to happen we're still
looking at kind of a cultural revolution
in the way that that people have
difficulty wrapping their heads around
the fact that their cars are going to
drive themselves it's undeniable that
you know there is this it's been called
the ick factor of people trying to wrap
their heads around the idea of eating
something that's called meat that didn't
come from an animal in the way that they
understand it so this is a hurdle that
were a drug we talked about this last
time a little bit but I think it's worth
kind of walking us through this aspect
of culture change yeah I mean people
don't eat meat because of how its
produced they eat meat despite how it's
produced so a researcher at Oklahoma
State University in early 2018 what
happened was a group called the
sentience Institute which is a sort of
animal protection think-tank they
released numbers and they said according
to our numbers more than 45% of people
would ban slaughterhouses said they want
slaughterhouses banned um and so the
meat industry said you know this could
not be true on look at the source so
they went to one of their hand-picked
researchers an Ag researcher at Oklahoma
State University and he did the
researcher research and he was like sure
enough and our poll forty-seven percent
of people want to ban slaughterhouses
two-thirds of people are uncomfortable
with the way that animals are raised
today so I think people like driving
their cars like you know what they like
about driving is not necessarily and
only getting from point A to point B I
think there's also a control issue of
like sort of sitting in the back of the
car where the car is driving around that
it's a little harder for people to wrap
their minds around I would say this is
more like going from the horse and buggy
to a car or going from a standard camera
to a digital camera or going from a you
know dial phone with the cord to go into
yourself
like what you like about taking pictures
or talking on the phone or eating me
what you like about it with me that's
taste its texture its experience its
culture its whatever it is but for
almost nobody it's I really want animals
to be raised and slaughtered for this so
if we can give people the taste the
texture the things that they like about
meat and we can get at a lower price
point I mean I really have just
absolutely no doubt that it takes off
and early polling is super good early
polling on this is super super good I
think there was I saw stat twenty to
thirty percent of people are willing to
make the switch twenty to thirty percent
of people are willing to pay more for
cleaners that way people who are willing
to try it is somewhere on the
consistently on the order of 70 percent
mm-hmm people are willing to make the
switch like permanently or in the order
of fifty percent and this is programming
against human physiology which has
forever told us you don't eat something
unfamiliar until like lots of other
people have eaten at first or it might
kill you
like you just basically say if we could
grow meat directly from cells without
animal slaughter you know what would you
think of that and most people are
excited about it and as we were talking
about a minute ago especially younger
people are super excited about it
and bear in mind right now plant-based
meat is a third of one percent of the
meat market and we're talking seventy
percent of people who would eat clean me
which is you know three times two
hundred and ten times as many people
before we even have a product like once
we actually have these products on sale
on shelves and we're saying do you want
the product that might have a whole
bunch of bacteria and might kill your
family and maybe laced with antibiotics
and here's how the animals were raised
in slaughter or do you want this other
safer cleaner product that doesn't have
all of those ancillary costs I don't
think like you're not gonna have a be a
map have to be a Madison Avenue genius
to sell the clean meat right well if I
was a venture capitalist you just gave
me the pitch of all time right I'd be
like take all my money but it also I
think it there is a little bit of a fear
button with people too they're like well
is this genetically engineered and I
heard that might not be so good and
what's the long-term you know we don't
know what this is doing to our bodies
long term like I've you know in in
fairness like I think we have to have
those conversations oh yeah absolutely
too you know
really make sure that we're doing all of
this right but you made an interesting
analogy in an article you wrote between
this movement and kind of what went down
with the in-vitro fertilisation movement
which I thought was apt yeah no I mean
it's so 40 years ago
I mean ethicists and lots of other
people were screaming bloody murder
murder at the idea of in-vitro
fertilization they were saying it's
unnatural and just like real absolute
freak out super controversy and now
we're 40 years later and there's no
controversy at all it's how I think like
2% of babies now are born through in for
in-vitro fertilization and they're you
know maybe some Jesuit academics who are
still raising concerns or some very
conservative old bioethicists but for
the most part this is like completely
non-controversial super common most
people know you know have family members
or friends who have had babies through
in vitro fertilization it's just that's
what it is in the same way it was
controversial originally when we were
gonna make ice and ice makers instead of
pulling ice out of you know cold lakes
and rivers and there was an uproar and
now there's you know obviously no
hyperaware at all it's a it's a safer
better cheaper right like ice was
controversial ice was controversial yeah
I didn't know that
yeah Paul Shapiro talks about it in his
book clean meat and lots of it talk
about that yeah other things in the same
that in in the same sort of vein but um
yeah this will I mean it there will be
certain people who are concerned about
this early on and there will be some
interests that try to drum up even more
concern about this early on but it is
just a much better product it's
perfectly safe and it's worth noting
that all of the people who have started
companies so far like most of them are
in this because they want their lives to
be meaningful
so uma valetti who started Memphis meats
he said I calculated that as a
cardiologist which is what he was doing
before he was a professor of cardiology
at the University of Minnesota trained
in cardiology at the Mayo Clinic which
is where he got the idea for growing
cells for meat he was the head of both
the American College of Cardiology and
the American Heart Association for the
Twin Cities so like a really you know he
could do kind of anything and this is
what he decided to do and he decided to
do
because he realized he could save even
more lives and do more good in the world
by accelerating the advancement of clean
meat than he could do as a cardiologist
and that's kind of the way that most
people in plant-based meat and clean
meat are thinking about this from brown
and Ethan Brown yeah Ethan for sure Josh
Tetrick the same thing yeah and so they
all want to be completely transparent
like they are consumer focused you know
maybe even slightly too up to a fault if
you're sort of an old school sort of
food marketing person but they want to
be completely transparent and I think
probably even from an old school sort of
food marketing with a new technology for
all the reasons you just enumerated you
really do want to make sure that people
are super comfortable and have a
complete understanding of the technology
and how it works and you know
everybody's talking about we're gonna be
live-streaming meat production on the
internet you want to see Memphis meats
you don't want to see the meat that you
are going to be eating being made you
know log in to Memphis meats calm and
click on the live stream it gets boring
in about 30 seconds but it makes it the
fact that it exists I mean this is super
important you know people want to be
connected to how their food is made yeah
its products are made how everything
they purchase is made and transparency
is no longer you know something to be
dismissed I think it needs to be front
and center and the fact that they're
doing that I think is amazing and it's
tart it stands of course in stark
contrast to the way you know meat and
dairy products have been produced
historically and how they're protected
through ag-gag laws and all kinds of
regulations that insulate the consumer
from the very truth of how these things
are created yeah I mean for people who
don't know what an AG gag law as Mark
Bittman from the New York Times coined
to the term AG gag and in states have
been passing these laws to make it
illegal to find out how meat is made
there are a variety of these laws the
early ones were you can't tape inside a
factory farm or a slaughterhouse or any
sort of facility that goes toward
raising animals for food so you've got
the plant-based meat and then clean meat
companies saying come one come all and
good luck getting into a modern farm or
a modern slaughterhouse you know then
that goes back to people eat meat
despite that not because of that
so these technologies I think once
the price is competitive and once it is
taste identical or better I don't see
many people not switching mm-hmm well
that's a perfect segue into a certain
sector of the economy that is somewhat
resistant to this which is the meat and
dairy producers themselves for every
Cargill or Tyson there's a whole variety
of other ongoing concerns that would
prefer to not have this succeed and
we're seeing this battle taking place in
the frontlines of it right now are over
labeling right yep so tell me about
what's going on with the meat labeling
thing I know you guys have jumped in
there's an injunction like this is super
fascinating to me yeah it's it's been
surprising to me and I should just say
there aren't really there isn't a
company that's similar to Tyson or
Cargill that is not on our side here the
cattle ranchers and the dairy producers
are pretty much the only folks who are
not excited about me directly
threatening their livelihood so you
almost can't blame them like this is how
they make a living yeah no I think
that's exactly right but it I do I guess
it's just to sort of underline people
who work in slaughterhouses like it
threatens their livelihoods but those
are just the worst jobs Human Rights
Watch said that the way that
slaughterhouse workers are treated in
the u.s. is the USS Human Rights crime
but people who are working in chicken
farms and pig farms like those folks are
not excited to be working in chicken
farms and pig farms so kind of the only
people with a vested interest who care
about this stuff are the dairy producers
there are still tens of thousands of
small dairy farms and cattle ranchers
there are still I don't know how many
but lots of cattle ranchers so that's
kind of the only folks in the resistance
to this sort of move in this direction
and technologically and it's our
position that they shouldn't be it's our
position that plant-based meat clean
meat and these alternative products they
actually will create better livelihoods
for farmers it's been go big or go home
for such a long time and so we've gone
from what more than 50% of people in
farming to fewer than 2% of people in
farming and they all have to be for the
most part really really massive this
allows us to open up all
different crops to cultivation you can
have smaller farms you can have farms
that you actually are able to do crop
rotation like this is sort of a new
agricultural Renaissance that will be
good for farmers but there are there
programs underway to help train these
people so that they can segue into a new
way of using their their land this is
one of the things that there is some
really interesting stuff happening in
this regard I was actually just chatting
with Kathy Freston my co-author and the
book clean protein and she was just out
in Arkansas she got an email from
somebody who read one of her books and
emailed her and apparently emailed four
people and Kathy was the only one who
replied and it's a chicken farmer from
Arkansas they have more than a hundred
thousand chickens supplying one of the
biggest chicken companies in the United
States and Shawn Monson the film maker
was out there with Kathy filming them as
they are basically moving out and
they're gonna go to hemp and there are
other farmers who are going to mushrooms
and other farmers are going to other
crops so this is the transition that we
think is going to have to happen our
hope is that governments as they fund
plant-based meat and clean meat research
will also fund programs to help people
who are currently in the current
industry to transition into these new
jobs that are actually absolutely coming
that are also just you know better for
the soil which is something that farmers
care about like farmers are not mono
cropping because they're excited about
mono cropping they're mono cropping to
stay alive essentially but to the
labeling issue there is there are the
different the dairy industry has for
decades been trying to convince the
government that soy milk should not be
called soy milk and almond milk
shouldn't be called almond milk there
have been class-action suits which are
really fun to read the judicial opinions
on the class-action suits like the
judges get very very creative and you
know it begs credulity that somebody
would be buying almond milk and think
they're getting you know milk that comes
from cows and right there are that do
these almonds lactate like it gets
really weird it gets really really weird
but in that that is all just because you
know these these sorts of endeavors
don't pass the smell test
but the Hail Marys they are absolute
Hail Marys but I mean they did passed a
law in Missouri that says that you can't
use meat terminology on the pack
of products unless those products come
from raised and slaughtered animals and
so we along with the animal Legal
Defense Fund and the ACLU of Missouri
and the plant-based Meat Company
tofurkey and then GFI GFI is both one of
the lawyers and one of the plaintiffs in
the case we're suing the state of
Missouri to overturn that law and the
main the main argument is that it's
unconstitutional unless the labels are
false or misleading Missouri can't
censor speech we also have the dormant
Commerce Clause argument in there as
well as a due process clause in there
what does the dormant Commerce Clause
argument the dormant Commerce Clause
argument is essentially that it was very
clear when the legislation was being
passed it was passed by the cattle
industry so it is to protect Missouri
cattle interests against competition
from other states so that's the dormant
Commerce Clause argument and then the
due process is void for vagueness you
read the law and it's very unclear the
only way you know what it is actually
supposed to do is if you read the
legislative history and so due process
demands that if you're going to be
convicted of a crime you have to know
what it looks like to violate the crime
and that's become even into starker
relief and sort of the conversations
that have been had after the law passed
but so we're suing we're about to be
asking for a preliminary injunction to
enjoin the government against actually
enforcing the law until our lawsuit is
over and the defendants argument
curiously is that they do not want
consumers to be confused rights they
want to make sure that these consumers
know where their food came from and the
inherent irony of course and all of that
goes back to what we were just talking
about they have enacted all of these
laws these protectionist measures to
prevent that very thing they actually
don't want consumers to know how those
products are produced so it feels like
this bizarre straw man it's almost
laughable that that's their argument
it is it is darkly ironic for sure no
and and we saw this of course Hampton
Creek which is now called just went
through this in the mayonnaise sector
right that the word mayonnaise must mean
must by its very definition means
eggs and that was a lawsuit that was
pursued by Unilever
correct yeah a PR nightmare I mean you
know Lee yeah turned into a peanut PR
nightmare Unilever not only dropped
their lawsuit but subsequently
introduced their own vegan I was gonna
say so yeah they've jumped on board you
know which i think is that's a beautiful
thing yeah we thought like sir
Kensington right they did by Sir
Pennington yeah you're you're in tune
with this stuff but how this much is you
I try you know I try to pay attention
from the sidelines but but yeah one at
one of GF is for programmatic
departments is our corporate engagement
Department and we have really good
relationships with Tyson and Cargill and
Smithfield and Unilever and all of these
big food companies like when GFI started
we were talking about disrupting the
food industry disrupting the meat dairy
and egg industries now we're talking
about transforming because of the more
we have conversations with these people
the more we realize that they you know
they're in this for whatever reason
they're in this but if they can do what
they want to do which has nothing to do
with raising and slaughters and
slaughtering animals if they can like
provide high-quality food to people in a
more efficient way that is more
profitable without all of the external
costs they're all in on that yeah so so
that was that was sort of an interesting
scenario and yeah Unilever they dropped
the lawsuit but then the FDA got
involved and it's all based on standards
of identity from like the early 1930s
and they don't make a lot of sense and
as apply in some cases they're not
constitutional they can't pass First
Amendment scrutiny and they would also
make things like gluten-free bread you
know bread has a standard of identity so
you can't have gluten
gluten-free bread you can't have rice
noodles there are tons of things that
according to the dairy industry's
interpretation of things wouldn't be on
shelves and it I mean their position is
just literally indefensible it's so
important and powerful this idea of
disrupting within if you want to use
that word or finding a way to
collaborate and cooperate with what is
to try to improve it we have it we had a
panel at this Kellogg School of Business
and we had the senior sustain at this
senior VP for sustainability at Tyson
Foods just in Whitmore and he was just
so awesome on this panel but one of the
things he said has released
with me he said it Tyson we don't want
to be disrupted we want to be the
disrupter and that is absolutely the way
that the entire food industry should be
thinking about this and we've been super
encouraged that that a lot of them
really are I mean one of the biggest
plant-based meat companies in the u.s.
is called light light and if you go to
light life's website light light comm
I'm sure it says meat without the
middleman
so like the largest meat company in
Canada maple leaf owns light life and
they are all in on this is me it's just
meat made from plants mm-hmm they're
also the owners of field roast which had
the second highest growth in the last
year at almost 70 percent just behind
behind me yeah that's amazing I mean I
feel like as amazing as the vegan
movement is there are factions within
the vegan movement that get in their own
way like you know for example somebody
who would say how dare you talk to Tyson
how do you know these these are the bad
guys these this is the enemy we're
trying to tear these people down but
they exist they're not necessarily going
away so what is the best strategy like
what is the battle that you're trying to
are you trying to win the battle or the
war for exactly and you're fighting the
war you're fighting this long term you
have a long term view on how to succeed
and it requires collaboration and
cooperation and and and some level of of
humanity right seeing these people as
people who want to do the right thing
and and they are I mean it's not even
you know it's it's sort of like Martin
Luther King jr. talks about how he
adopted non-violence in the 50s as a
tactic you know he read about Gandhi and
he adopted non-violence and he just sort
of thought they're way more powerful
than we are there's no way we're gonna
win with violence we adopted
non-violence as a tactic then by the
early 60s he's like no non-violence is
just you know deontological non-violence
is the only way to victory and success
it's not a tactic it's just an absolute
moral imperative and I think similarly
some people may see let's work with
Tyson as a tactic I see it as a moral
imperative I mean it certainly is the
most the way that we are most likely to
be successful but it's also true like I
know the people at Tyson and Cargill and
Unilever and these
deniz and we go in and we spend an
entire day with these folks talking
about plant-based meat and clean meat
they are good people
just like you know the people in the
vegan movement are good people everybody
who is vegan knows lots of people who
they love who are not vegan and
hopefully we don't think they're bad
people but those are not vegan so the
fact that somebody has found themselves
you know in the upper echelons this one
of these corporations allows them to do
a lot more good than 99.9999% of vegans
because they can be a part of the
transformation and the inside and if we
look at them as you know human beings
which they who they are trying to do
good in the world which they are rather
than sort of any sense of enemy I mean a
that's just true and be it's also going
to be tactically a lot smarter yeah if
they have their hands on the archimedes
lever that can create seismic major
shifts and you know how we think about
food how we produce food how we eat food
how we how we innovate a brighter future
that is protective of our planet for
future generations to come that spares
all of these animals that improves our
health I mean it checks all the boxes
yeah and anybody can see that
right I mean you don't have to be vegan
you don't have to be an activist like
most of these people have families they
want the best for their children and
their grandchildren and themselves and
the world so that's a that's like also
just a nicer conversation to have you
know then you are bad and and I started
I started learning this I was at People
for the Ethical Treatment of yeah you
were at PETA for a long time so this is
you've had your own personal kind of
journey and exploration to this place as
well yeah I remember in the early 2000s
at PETA we started launching corporate
campaigns to reform industrial animal
agriculture and we got a professional
business consultant who taught business
I think at University of Illinois if
memory serves a guy named Steve gross
and the first thing he said to me and
you know we couldn't have afforded him
but he was doing it pro bono and he now
is I think chair of the board of a group
called farm forward and so he was our
negotiator with McDonald's with KFC with
Wendy's with Safeway and calling up sort
of all of the big fast food and grocery
outlets and he said you
we are absolutely going to get nowhere
if we go in with confrontation we have
to go in with you know let me tell you
about my son and my daughter and here's
what my son and my daughter are doing
tell me about your son and your daughter
you know what do you want for the future
of the world be sort of highfalutin
things and this is another example we
might not change people's diets
necessarily with these sorts of
conversations or at least not as many as
we want to change some people change I
changed you change but but if we really
want to bond with people and create
transformation we need to do it at a
human level so that's been sort of my
philosophy since then and I think it's
you know it's correct it's correct and I
think it applies to how we're having
conversations about everything right now
you know the the dialogue that we're
seeing online especially in the
political sphere even in the health and
nutrition sphere is pretty toxic you
know it's pretty toxic and I think we
need to take a step back and really try
to understand how to better communicate
our our point of view and I think it
begins with some level of humility and
compassion for other people and the
inherent humanity that we all share I
just I was at a conference this past
weekend in in Nantucket this thing
called the Nantucket project and that
was kind of a theme of this event the
theme for this year was neighborhood and
it was very consciously curated in terms
of the speaker line-up to to cultivate
like this conversation around how to
really communicate effectively so that
we can come together and and and make
positive change in the world so there
were polarizing figures on there was
Sean Spicer there was George W Bush
there was Lance Armstrong there was
Valerie Plame like a very interesting
mix of individuals who in their own
worlds are polarizing for a lot of
people and all of the conversations that
took place were were about like let me
see if I can see this from this person's
point of view
like what is it like for that person as
a human being and I left that experience
a better person because I really did
force myself to set aside my
preconceived ideas and whatever
projections I'm putting on all of these
people and and I left with a greater
sense of compassion and I think that we
need more of that you know we need that
in the vegan movement we need that in
these conversations that we're having
about politics and certainly with
respect to what you do which is
interfacing with these titans of
industry who are in you know
organizations that when you were at PETA
you know you had a very different
perspective on right or so it's really
interesting that you're now creating the
most change that you've ever had in your
entire career by taking a very different
psychological and communicative approach
yeah well it helps a tremendous amount
that I mean what we I had the same basic
attitude at PETA but what we were asking
them to do was a lot harder yeah I mean
so you're you know you're asking them to
be the industry leader and it is going
to adversely affect their profitability
so they were harder conversations they
were still good conversations but now
we're actually you know we're saying
this is why this will be more profitable
for you mm-hmm and it's simultaneously
you know you should do it for all these
very human reasons but it's in your best
interest but it's in your best interest
which may want to get rich yeah it makes
it it makes it makes it a much easier
conversation so what's going on on the
regulatory landscape right now with the
FDA the USDA are the hurdles there is
this smooth sailing like what does that
look like I mean the sort of paratha
Tory thing to say in response to that
question is that there are you know 190
something countries and every country
has the capacity to introduce clean meat
so plant-based meat you know obviously
it's plant-based mean so it's all foods
that are already in the food supply so
there are some regulatory questions they
mostly have to do with labeling and
safety testing for new ingredients but
the really interesting question has to
do with clean meat and in the United
States there's a bit of a battle in July
FDA asserted its unalloyed authority and
said base essentially they had a whole
they meeting at which the Commissioner
and the woman who runs the Center for
food and nutrition and their chief
scientist just said we got this we got
this we got this which is kind of what
GFI thought should happen and we still
think should happen the current
regulatory regime is up to the task and
it makes the most sense for FDA to do it
because these are the sorts of products
that they have been regulating for
decades but USDA also wants in on it
and the cattle ranchers want USDA to be
in on it so there's a little bit of a
battle in the United States I mean it
looks like everybody thinks that the
current regulatory regime is up to the
task
if I were a betting person I would bet
that there will be some sort of dual
Authority from USDA and FDA so maybe FDA
will do safety testing pre market and
then USDA will actually regulate the
production and the labeling but it's
hard to say for sure and obviously
Congress could jump and jump in and just
sort of dictate and which case you know
whatever FDA or USDA wants would be a
relevant Congress Congress would just
say but we're optimistic the National
Academies of Sciences released a report
about two years ago in which they said
this is a very promising technology and
the government should do everything that
it can to make sure that the current
regular regulatory regime is used no new
regulatory promulgation and also that it
is smooth and quick and since again this
is something I mean this is not sort of
your average regulatory discussion of
food this is a regulatory discussion of
a food that solves a lot of problems
then the government once solved so
hopefully this sort of normative
considerations will also be worked in
but we're simultaneously like in our in
our overseas offices the focus is policy
and science so the focus is a convinced
the government's on the policy side one
side of policy has convinced these
governments to fund open source
plant-based and clean meat research and
then the other side is roll out the
regulatory red carpet for clean meat so
we're doing analysis in all of these
countries then the other side is if
you're they're gonna fund the science we
need the scientists so we're doing a lot
of outreach to scientists in these
countries to get them excited about
right yeah I would think in the in the
u.s. it would be advisable to bring the
PA in as well like because it impact
it's not just food right this is a
bigger this is a bigger subject matter
with more profound implications beyond
like what are the ingredients and you
know is it is it healthy for human
consumption yeah I mean I think there
are many other agencies which especially
if you're talking about funding EPA has
a research and development budget it
used to go significantly to climate
change initiatives and now it's going to
a variety of other environmental things
but some of that money could certainly
be made available to plant-based meat
and clean meat research and development
but if what you're talking about is
regulatory oversight you know you've got
the Food and Drug Administration under
the Food Drug and Cosmetic Act they
oversee about 80% of food then you've
got the USDA the federal Meat Inspection
Act and they oversee the vast majority
of meat oversight and so this is meat
but it also uses a lot of the sort of
food technologies that have generally
been the province of FDA so at least by
regulatory oversight it will either be
FDA or USDA or some combination of FDA
right yeah yeah it's confusing it's a
little more over that yeah the food
system in the United States is
definitely considered is definitely
concerned confusing well I think most
people think that the USDA is this
government organization that functions
like a consumer watchdog that has our
best interests at heart and I think a
lot of people would be surprised to
learn that it's only a quasi government
organization that functions in many ways
like a lobbying arm for the dairy
industry well yeah meat and dairy I mean
oh yeah you at USDA was set up to
promote us agriculture and I think it
was the 1960s that it became also
focused on food safety but it definitely
appears to be more promote US
agriculture than it than it does food
safety and we have the only Department
of Agriculture in the world that doesn't
have mandatory recall powers like you
will always see the meat industry a
voluntary recall and it's oh it's a
voluntary recall you know this mushroom
that must not be that too toxic
100 percent of recalls are voluntary
recalls because USDA is not empowered
with the authority to issue a mandatory
that's really remarkable and that it's
the checkoff program right yeah I spoke
I spoke with Neal Barnard about that but
explain what that is because that's just
a mind-blower that that even is a thing
well there are a bunch of different
checkoff programs so of course again
USDA was was set up to promote u.s.
agriculture so there's a beef checkoff
and a dairy checkoff and a cheese
checkoff and basically a percentage of
all cheese dairy and beef sales in the
United States go into government
administered checkoff programs that then
do general promotion of those products
and they're pretty controversial because
the small producers uniformly feel like
what's true which is it's a sort of
lowest common denominator promotion for
the entire industry and then you get
into sort of weird legal ramifications
as well where the laws that affect the
general population generally don't also
affect the federal government so the
federal government can do things that if
it were a private corporation it would
be illegal to do which happened when
there was this lawsuit in California
this happened in California over there's
happy cows commercials happy cows come
from California and so PETA and I think
the Animal Legal Defense Fund and some
other folks sued and the defense was not
these commercials are true the defense
was the government does not have to
abide by the consumer protection laws
that apply to corporations and that was
the reason that that that lawsuit ended
up being ejected despite the fact that
even people on the board who are
watching the commercials and the focus
groups were saying I don't think all of
the cows in California are an on-rails
in Sonoma and isn't it like I know that
that when dairy products find their way
into television commercials like when
Pizza Hut introduces its cheesy crust
and it's that there is government
funding going into those ad budgets ya
know it's fat it's fascinating I mean
that's that's what yeah it's the
American Egg Board and the American
Dairy Council and the Beef Council and
the pork board like those are quasi
governmental agencies I mean in part
that's why Hampton Creek when they there
was this crazy thing where the American
Egg Board was laughing about killing
Josh Tetrick and was trying to keep
emails
came out and they're trying to keep
Hampton Creek products off the shelves
of Whole Foods and all kinds of
anti-competitive stuff that is illegal
for these groups to do because they are
government-funded and the reason those
emails came out is that because they are
government-funded they're also subject
to FOIA yeah they run for a request yeah
so all that stuff came back and a
Freedom of Information Act request and
it was interesting what the what
happened in response to that was that
the meat industry tried to pass a law to
make FOIA more restrictive so their
response was not oh my god you know this
is an awful thing joking about you know
killing a competitor and obviously
anti-competitive stuff their response
was let's see if we can make the next
FOIA
not actually get the records and
fortunately FOIA is something that you
know the far right the far left and the
center all agree on
so that legislation went absolutely
nowhere but but that was the response of
the sort of meat industry right large
which was too bad all right so the
players I'm familiar with Memphis meats
I know what beyond me impossible are
doing and the plant based sector just
and just shettrick they're they're
getting into clean meat now they are who
are the other players like what's going
on
now that's new like you know what are
some of the products that are being
developed and and who are some of the
other active members of this this this
movement there's a lot of really
exciting stuff happening across
plant-based meat and clean meat so as
you know the 12 months that ended early
September there was 23% growth and
plant-based meat and at the grocery
sector and beyond meat was number one at
70% and it would have been a lot higher
if they could have met demand but number
two was field roast which is sort of a
legacy producer that's owned by a meat
company in Canada number three was
Gardein number four was dr. preggers so
we are seeing a lot of the sort of
old-school plant-based meat companies
significantly upping their game
improving their products improving their
marketing and recognizing that they too
can get really really big so that's
exciting
the Sarno's are getting into fish
- right yeah that that company is
exciting it's called good catch it's
actually one of GFI's three success
stories so in our innovation department
in addition to helping startups to be
successful and publishing all kinds of
documents to help we've got a start-up
guide which is a kind of everything in
anything you've ever wanted to know
about starting a plant-based or clean
meat food business and we help companies
with whatever they want but we have also
started three companies one of those
companies that we started with a with a
marketing company called beyond brands
and a venture capital fund called new
crop capital is good catch and good
catches they sponsored our conference
and also did the me did the did the
reception on Thursday evening so the
first night of the conference and people
who eat tuna we're eating their tuna and
we're just blown away yeah they've also
got crab cakes and they're gonna be
rolling out a bunch of other fish
alternatives and two of the chefs behind
that are Derek Sarno and Chad Sarno who
have also been GFI advisors from from
when we were first conceived super cool
is there good catch products should be
on the market on certainly by the end of
the year so usually out for them yeah
and they have a line of products in the
UK too like I was just in London and you
can go into their you know version of
7-eleven or what else can I have pre
prepackaged healthy you know sandwiches
and things like that that are all
totally plant-based yeah wicked healthy
yeah as the brand and they're going to
be launching in the US a brand called
wicked meaty which is which is also
something that new crop capital and the
good food Institute started working on
together cool so if you can grow meat
products in this fashion from these
cells I would presume that you could
also create cheese and dairy products as
well yeah true what's going on there so
those are a cellular products of course
so you go straight to the proteins
rather than a cells and that's actually
quite a bit easier so you just isolate
the proteins you do need to use genetic
modification so the final product is not
GMO but there is a GMO process so you
can take a GMO yeast or a GMO bacteria
and you get whatever the proteins are
that you want the yeast or the bacteria
to grow and you program that directly
into the East and out it comes and it's
a genetically identical thing so you can
create cheese or milk or egg proteins on
eggs and milk and cheese are pretty
complex but once you actually have the
key proteins that give it the binding or
they give it the flavor they give it the
you know whatever it is that you like
about cheese or milk or eggs it's
probably going to be an easier process
than meat although it is the case that
there are far fewer companies doing it
so the absolute leader in dairy is a
company called perfect day which is
being funded by the richest guy in Asia
guy named li kai-shing who has a venture
capital fund called horizons ventures
and he's the money behind horizons
ventures the main egg company is a
company called Clara foods and then
there's also a gelatin company called
gel tour mmm the world is getting crazy
Bruce it is getting crazy we I mean we
really think there should be a lot more
plant-based meat innovation so
plant-based meat companies that are
focused on biomimicry that are focused
on food tech like good catch is a
phenomenal company company and they're
doing a great job with tuna they're
mostly focused on culinary I think
they're in slogan or something like chef
mastered I can't remember exactly but I
mean I they really focus on sort of the
chef side of things and that's exciting
but there is a tremendous amount that
could be done with food tech and some
people I think maybe have the idea that
impossible and beyond meat have that
corner they absolutely don't it's still
1/3 of 1% of the market so we would like
to see a lot more companies saying let's
see what happens if we use Lupin let's
see what happens if we use chickpeas
let's see what happens if we use millet
and like all of these under explored
proteins and turn that into plant-based
main yeah and the plant-based dairy
market cap is massive oh yeah no I mean
it's interesting plant-based dairy has
just surpassed 13% of the dairy market
it was 10% I think two years ago so it
is continuing to grow in a way that is
very exciting more and more companies
more and more market share yeah and I
think we're only going to continue to
see that especially as the price comes
down I mean it's at 13% despite being
more expensive mm-hm
once it gets to price parity I think
it's a really interest barriers from
what I
gather from our conversation our really
capital like making sure that all of
these ventures are properly funded
training the brightest minds to enter
into this sector to continue to innovate
I mean what are some of the other like
hurdles that you're trying to overcome
right now those are really the two big
hurdles I mean if you go ask Ethan Brown
or Pat Brown from beyond meet and
impossible foods or you ask
Uma valetti or Mike Selden from finless
or Lou Cooper house from blue knew Lou
or sort of any of these companies right
now they're not having funding issues
like every time they go to get the
amount of money that they think they can
effectively incorporate the money is
there so far but what they're not
finding is the crackerjack scientists
the tissue engineers the biochemists the
meat scientists the chem the mechanical
engineers the people to design these
technologies to make this you know
market sector thrive um so so far they
have the money when I talk about needing
money I'm talking about governments
should be putting billions of dollars in
creating research institutes that hasn't
happened yet and it should but so far no
startup in this space has failed due to
lack of money although the most money
that's been raised is Memphis meets at
21 million dollars so that alesis has
not been thoroughly tested they're gonna
have to raise hundreds of millions of
dollars to be successful and we're super
optimistic that they'll be able to do
that but that money is gonna have to be
there but the talent gap is number one
and number two and number three really
in terms of obstacles at the moment
which is why GFI is excited to be
launching fellowship programs at top
universities internationally where we
have identified a huge opportunity for a
plant-based meat and clean meat even if
it's not there quite yet we just really
need to create a talent pool of people
who are excited to staff these companies
right so all you super genius is out
there what are you doing I know exactly
come on look at this look at this
expanding universe the world is your
oyster your world the world is your
plant based clean meat oyster
yeah and for you if people are wondering
how they get involved I mean especially
if you're in college science science
science if you're in high school science
if you're beyond that
I mean think about other ways that you
can dedicate your talent to that I mean
obviously philanthropists the GFI GFI we
have to raise 7.5 million dollars this
year so we'd love your help if you have
access to even more money than that or
you have access to people who you could
connect us with who would help us raise
tens of millions of dollars to create
Institute's if you have access to
government's raise these issues with
governments they should be putting even
more money into this but we do have a
lot of job openings in GFI you know GFI
needs scientific and other help we need
lawyers we need people in our corporate
engagement Department we need people in
our policy Department when you you know
kind of across the organization yeah
you're growing all right so all you
other super geniuses out there get in
touch with Bruce man yeah he wants to
hire you and if you're if you're
extroverted and can do sort of marketing
stuff and meeting with corporations we
need we need that too yeah all kinds of
people all right well we got to wrap
this up but I think a good place to kind
of leave people with is is your version
of of the future like paint me the
picture of the future that you're
working towards that you would like to
see um boy you can go very very big with
that I mean I before I got involved in
this space I ran a homeless shelter in a
soup kitchen in inner-city Washington DC
for about six years I also taught for
through Teach for America for a couple
of years so my vision my vision of the
future is people well fed people well
educated everybody has health care it's
a future where people have the capacity
to take a step back and reflect on their
lives people are practicing mindfulness
from the highest to the lowest echelon
and a part of that is the good food
future for sure a part of that is if
people are eating meat its plant-based
meat or it's clean meat but it's also
just a world where I mean we are going
to knock out global poverty probably in
the next 20 or 30 years we need to go
from knocking out global poverty to like
real health and health care and
prosperity and spirituality and
mindfulness and I think plant-based meat
and clean maid it's sort of on maslov's
period pyramid the plant-based meat
unclean meat a part of the the base and
it's like we need to people gotta feed
everybody
Yeah right yeah global health needs to
be taken care of the environment needs
to be taken care of our basic
physiological needs but I want everybody
up at self-actualization and I'd love to
see that happen by 2050 you and me both
births you and me both
well you're doing a tremendous amount to
get us there rich I think your podcast I
mean that the podcast with you ball
Harare really blew me away the podcast
with the religious figure talking about
the human need for spirituality
you know just they're just raising these
issues with your listeners I think it's
just so exciting and doing such a
service yeah well I appreciate that the
work you're doing at GFI is incredible
you really are reshaping the world I
commend you I wish you well and if
there's anything I can do to continue to
support your mission please don't
hesitate to reach out having me honest
as I mentioned it's it's just such an
honor and also such a help so thank you
you're a gift my friend quite often when
people listen to podcast they have an
option on their phone like they can
speed it up to like one and a half times
or two times so they can listen to to
our podcast in an hour but you're firing
off so much information I feel like
people are gonna have to go the other
direction and play it at half speed just
so they can process everything that you
have said that's hilarious cool if you
want to connect with Bruce GFI org
indeed and Bruce Friedrich on Twitter
yes Bruce G free drinks on friedrich
sweater in linkedin yeah there you go
man and are you giving any speeches
public appearances or anything like that
I am kind of always giving speeches and
public appearances if people sign up for
the GFI newsletter you'll you'll find
out about them
there you go all right pleasure my
friend thanks Richard
peace peace plants clean meat yeah
[Music]
you